The Joe Rogan Experience are you done
are you done fighting 100 I'm done
you're done I'm done 100 and it was hard
for me to get out after being in there
for 20 years and that's your identity
yeah you know and and then I just kind
of got into trying to be a father
you know and I was doing that thing try
to be around more
and then and then all this stuff
happened and I find myself in here but I
do think all the blood all the tears all
the sweat all the all the ups and downs
all the good media all the bad media all
of that was to prepare me
for for you know for this kind of you
know I I I see like everything that
they're gonna throw at me I can kind of
see like well I kind of been through
that yeah
yeah the mental Warfare
the mental Warfare that a fighter has to
go through I mean my God there's nothing
like it in all sports and you know when
I first got it decided to get into this
I was like you know
I I haven't I have I was just retired so
I wasn't trying to keep my everything
you know perfect in public and this and
I was just running around trying to I
was just a guy trying to come off of a
20-year
a journey of being the baddest man on
the planet and then I so it was tough it
was really tough to get over you know
that identity so as as time when you
know I was just living my life
some more ups and downs I like I say you
know sometimes I was judged fairly other
times I wasn't you know and BJ when you
were on top you were one of the baddest
[ __ ] on Earth you really were
you were a guy who went all the way up
to heavyweight to fight Leota Machida I
mean it's I remember that fight I mean
you did some wild [ __ ] dude and you were
strangling a lot of [ __ ] people man
and for jiu jitsu guys like for all my
Jiu Jitsu guys you were the [ __ ] man
because you were a smaller guy who
choked out Matt Hughes you know who was
so [ __ ] good at the time man and man
he was a tank when you got his back and
and choked him everybody's like oh [ __ ]
she gets his back people forgot
they forgot those times PJ and you know
there was a run like the Sean shirk days
Diego Sanchez days you were a scary
[ __ ] dude you were a scary
[ __ ] you were tuned in when you
were tuned in man you were something
fierce I always tell people you have to
judge a fighter by The Heights they
reached not where they fell afterwards
and or or the up and coming fights you
got to judge him by the heights that
they reached
you like a guy like Oliveira he's a
great example he's had some losses he's
been knocked out but you can't you got
to judge him by the height that he's out
now
you got to be accurate and then maybe he
can only sustain that for a few years at
the like Fedor could only stand for a
few years at the tippity top of
performance yes but you got to judge him
from that yeah I I it makes me sick when
people judge them by their worst
performances you know for you the your
best performances were spectacular you
had some crushing performances when you
were training with marinovic and they
got you in Tip Top Magoo shape dude you
were terrifying when you had that crazy
gas tank man I I I did I loved it you
know one of the marinovich uh wait
what's what's more individual yeah well
Mar passed away yeah but Gary's at my
house in Hawaii right now he's training
some football teams or something and he
he has to come down and it's great to
have how did that connection happen
because they basically changed the way
you did strength and conditioning right
yes well how did that how'd this
introduction happen they uh yeah how did
it my brother meant how did I run into
them
I forget how I exactly but I think my
brother introduced me to them and and
when they they were just Geniuses man
and no matter how good you are they were
50 years ahead I remember we were at uh
in UCLA or something and they had that a
little cone pattern and they had me run
it to see my agility and Marv said well
that's too slow and the lady said well
how do you know and he said because I
made it up
these guys were just ahead of everybody
that and like they were the guys with
the NFL combine and everything was speed
because he noticed that like the
strongest guys who had the strongest
Squad the biggest bench press and all
that they had the lowest numbers on the
field and then that's how we started to
put in the agility the speed the
movement the the reflexes and going back
so they were they were really ahead of
their time yeah it was wild to watch man
they looked like they were torturing you
it was you know what Looking Back Now I
see everybody and I look at them now all
who eats the most at the buffet the
hungriest one and that's the whole thing
no matter what I'll look and I'll just
be like is he still hungry that's the
only question I uh or or does he yeah
does he still want to eat as much
because literally a lot of these guys
they haven't ate filet mignon before
they have any Lobster and they're still
thinking about what that's going to
taste like when they get when they
finally get the opportunity to buy that
for their family yeah there's like a
balance right of how long you can
maintain that hunger yes how long can
you maintain that ferocity yep it has
nothing to do with who's the best it's
who wants it the most that's what it is
and that's what I thought about I mean I
kind of knew that about martial arts I
mean you go in there and you be right as
quick and as violent as and and as
intimidating as possible
when you get in there but believe me I
believe just like me even at my best I'm
like what can I get what can I do to
make the referee stop this how can I
make the referee stop this thing because
you're nervous right the hero and the
coward they're both scared but the hero
is going to step forward
yeah you were a wild [ __ ] in
your Prime brother you were a wild
[ __ ] you were fun to watch the
Dean Thomas fight there was a lot of
fights that were like holy [ __ ] nothing
else mattered to me in my life at that
time than than being the the toughest
and most skilled
martial artist on the planet and this
fighter I didn't consider myself a
martial artist I just thought of myself
as a fighter
I'll beat you up because you you were
you were certainly doing that man and so
when did you did you continue that kind
of strength and conditioning routine or
did you stop doing it after a while
um people start to fall apart and
different ideas and coaches start to
fight with each other and you know and I
that's what happened with with that
stuff Marv kind of went his own way
because as you get six weeks out from
the fight your boxing coach is screaming
he's got a spar he's got a spar and then
the other guy is like no this is enough
and and they start going and then it has
a reaction on you let's explain it to
everybody because this is the philosophy
the two different philosophies the the
marinovich's believe that you already
know how to fight all you need to do is
just get in ridiculous condition and so
they were just gonna put you through
that and what did you do like light
drills other than that like hitting pads
like what kind of stuff did you do but
no sparring right maybe not even pads
just different things speed a lot of
good stuff we do ladders we would do
that water workout stuff
and they thought that that was more
important than anything
yes and it was very important I will
never say that it wasn't you know and
then on the other side it's the same
it's people say do you coach you train I
say no but if I did I'll tell you what I
would do I would show up to the gym I'd
tell another coach that had his fighter
and I would say hey coach can my boy get
a couple rounds with your board up with
your boy tomorrow and then I look at my
guy and go kick his ass tomorrow and
then I'd leave him and make him go home
and think about it all night because the
act of the physical act of fighting that
ain't the fight it's the going home and
thinking about it all night long anybody
can get into a fight real quick in
school but when they say meet me at the
park after and the whole school shows up
now that's the fight you know or I'll
meet you in four months for a UFC card
right isn't that amazing that's when it
gets wild right when you plan in these
fights months out and everybody gets to
know that it's coming yes but that
that's it sleeping with that that is
that's what it's all about sleeping with
it controlling it internalizing it